llegó el momento de la información
económica en france 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañera
daniela blandón daniela bienvenida
empezamos hablando de rusia que es un
gran proveedor mundial de materias
primas y la guerra ha disparado los
precios o la valentina pues la lista es
bastante larga de todo lo que produce
rusia y lo que vende petróleo trigo
aluminio níquel entre muchos otros los
precios de todos estos commodities se
han disparado a máximos en varios años a
medida que avanza la guerra y esto
sucede no solamente por la incertidumbre
de los mercados sino también porque
rusia es un importante proveedor mundial
miremos es el tercer mayor productor de
petróleo después de eeuu y arabia
saudita y con este último se pelea el
primer lugar en exportaciones también
ocupa el segundo puesto en producción de
gas aunque en ventas externas es el
primero tiene asimismo un 5 por ciento
de la producción mundial de carbón y
ocupa el tercer puesto en exportaciones
principalmente con destino a china en
producción de oro solamente superan a
rusia australia y china y así sigue la
lista pasando por cobalto el titanio que
se usa para la fabricación de aviones el
paladio el platino y los diamantes de
los que produce una tercera parte en
todo el mundo bueno y la guerra que
parece tan lejana ya está golpeando a
américa latina en términos económicos
valentina y es que rusia no solamente es
un gran productor y exportador de
minerales e hidrocarburos también es uno
de los mayores proveedores de insumos
agrícolas como los fertilizantes de los
que provee un 13 por ciento del total
mundial con asia y brasil como sus
principales destinos el viernes el
ministerio de comercio e industria de
rusia recomendó a los productores de
fertilizantes suspender temporalmente
las exportaciones el análisis de este
tema lo hace jorge enrique bedoya él es
presidente de la sociedad de
agricultores de colombia con el caso de
los fertilizantes que solamente países
como rusia canadá eeuu son grandes
proveedores de fertilizantes para toda
latinoamérica
es así como brasil inclusive si no mira
la visita que hizo el presidente
bolsonaro a putin antes de que invadiera
a ucrania y vaya de la mano de las
necesidades de fertilizantes que tiene
brasil sobre todo por sus cosechas en
maíz soya café solo por mencionar unos
ejemplos en el caso nuestro de colombia
nosotros importamos más del 20 por
ciento de las necesidades de
fertilizantes y agroquímicos desde rusia
y un 10.3 de belorrusia no obstante de
canadá en los eeuu son probables muy
importantes para nosotros entonces
cualquier cosa que ocurra entre rusia y
ucrania las sanciones que se impongan a
rusia o inclusive el anuncio que hizo y
el ministerio de comercio de reducción
de un llamado a los exportadores de
fertilizantes preparar sus importes de
exportaciones pues compleja hace mucho
más complejo el tema de los precios
internacionales de esos insumos que son
críticos para garantizar la alimentación
no lo diría solamente en colombia sino a
nivel mundial bueno y ahora hablemos de
productos alimenticios un sector que
también rusia es protagonista pues
valentina los humidores de pan por
ejemplo en el mundo son algunos de los
que más están sintiendo la crisis en sus
bolsillos tanto rusia como ucrania son
exportadores de alimentos por excelencia
y la invasión de rusia del 24 de febrero
ha obstaculizado gravemente el comercio
desde los puertos del mar negro e
impulsando aún más la inflación mundial
de alimentos que ya era la más alta en
una década los detalles en el siguiente
informe de amal benotman y jorge hurtado
estos panaderos muy pronto podrían verse
obligados a apagar sus hornos en medio
oriente y el norte de áfrica millones de
personas dependen del suministro de
trigo de los dos protagonistas de la
guerra rusia y ucrania
países como egipto líbano yemen se
verían afectados por el aumento de los
precios del trigo o una interrupción del
suministro según el instituto de oriente
medio rusia es el primer exportador
mundial de trigo y ucrania y cuarto pero
el conflicto ha bloqueado los
principales puertos para el líbano
ucrania era la fuente del 80% de las 650
mil toneladas de trigo importadas
anualmente
allí la devastadora explosión del puerto
de beirut dejó al país con capacidad
para almacenar trigo para solamente un
mes a la vez mientras que túnez depende
de las importaciones ucranianas y rusas
para el 60 por ciento de su consumo
total de trigo
ambos países concentran juntos casi una
tercera parte de las exportaciones de
trigo una quinta parte de las de maíz y
80% de las de aceite de girasol
claramente los precios del petróleo y
los precios de la gasolina suben debido
a la crisis eso va a generar grandes
problemas en términos de la cadena de
suministro especialmente con la
interrupción de los puertos en el mar
negro y el impacto de las sanciones
el programa mundial de alimentos afirma
que solamente en síria 12 4 millones de
personas se enfrentan inseguridad
alimentaria que podría agravarse con un
conflicto que aunque parezca lejano
golpea cada día más cerca
y usted nos trae la cifra del día pues
complementando un poco la información
que veíamos en la anterior nota los
precios de los contratos más negociados
del trigo en la bolsa de chicago
subieron esta semana más del 40 por
ciento un butch el que es la es como una
medida utilizada para este para este
producto ahora vale poco más de 12
dólares un máximo en 14 años cuando al
inicio de la guerra costaba un poco más
de la mitad grave es el panorama que se
nos viene daniela ustedes muchas gracias
por esta ampliación y ustedes por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros en
france 24
ah
[Música]